now this is a really really important
topic if you have Gerd acid reflux
heartburn or bloating gas any digestive
symptoms this video is very very
important now one of the first things
that people normally do when they have
acid reflux is they go to their doctor
and they get it evaluated and then
they're put on a medication usually a
PPI or some type of antacid which
suppresses the acid now at first it
might seem logical you have this acid in
your stomach we got to get rid of it
right but the question is what causes
acid reflux well if you look it up it'll
say that acid reflux comes from the
valve on the top of the stomach not
closing properly all right well that's
cool but what causes that valve not to
be able to close well they don't really
know right and then my question is okay
you're going to put give me a medication
how long am I going to be on this is it
going to correct my problem what happens
when I start the medication and come off
are there rebound effects is it safe
well for certain ppis uh long-term
effects are really bad osteoporosis
increased risk of cancer increased risk
of gallstones increased risk of sibo
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
increased risk of anemia increased risk
of allergies and the list goes on and on
so you always want to ask how long am I
going to be on these beds for is it
going to be indefinitely and what are
the long-term problems and what is the
underlying cause of the problem these
are things that a lot of people don't
really ask and they don't find out about
I recently talked to a lady who was on I
mean she's fairly young I think she's in
her early 30s and she's on eight
medications right and she doesn't feel
well I mean how the heck are you going
to know what is causing what what is
creating different effects I mean I'm
not against poison I'm sorry medication
but when you're on that many medications
it's bound to create all sorts of issues
making you not feel good but when we're
talking about ppis anything that
suppresses the acid you really want to
think twice before getting that
medication but of course I need to give
you a disclaimer check with your doctor
before taking any of my advice so why
don't doctors recommend apple cider
vinegar
well mainly there's not a lot of studies
in relationship to acid reflux or gerd
using apple cider vinegar that's the big
reason who's going to invest that much
money to do a study because there's not
a lot of profit in selling apple cider
vinegar it's a very very inexpensive on
drugs yes but outside of vinegar no now
as far as myself being in practice for
30 years
I've run into thousands of patients who
had acid reflux who tried apple cider
vinegar and got great results of course
that's not a study but it's uh my own
personal observation that it really
really works so we're talking about this
acid an apple cider vinegar okay it's
called acetic acid in fact these little
bacteria acetic acid bacteria
live on rapes they live on different
foods especially when that grape becomes
ripened okay and then when they make
wine they're going to turn that grape
sugar into alcohol but during that
fermentation process they're going to
remove oxygen because one thing about
the acetic acid bacteria is they can't
live with oxygen and that's how you kill
them but if you allow this fermentation
process with the conversion from grapes
into alcohol to get oxygen it eventually
just turns right into vinegar now
there's some really really important
things to know about the stomach so if
you've checked out check back in right
now because this is very important
number one the normal pH
of someone's stomach should be between
one and three that is extremely acid
okay that's normal so when someone says
that you have too much acid and your
stomach uh what actually are they
talking about I mean normal acid is that
is acid as you can go like one to three
so what does this mean someone has too
much acid with acid reflux or gerd so
acid reflux heartburn and gerd are
really not a situation where you have
too much acid you just have acid in the
wrong place you have it in the esophagus
the acid should be in the stomach okay
so the real problem is that valve right
well that's a kind of a secondary
problem a deeper problem is the pH in
your stomach is not one to three it's
higher it's more alkaline it's not as
acid as it should be and there's a
sensing mechanism between the level of
pH in the stomach and your valve on the
top of the stomach they're both in
communication and so just think about it
it's it's logical that if you eat like
meat or something you need all that acid
right and you don't need the acid refl
flexing so that valve closes tightly if
the acid reaches a certain pH you need
it very very acid in the stomach and the
valve will close so the real underlying
cause behind gerd acid reflux and
usually bloating okay and heartburn is
that your strength of the acid the pH of
the acid is not between one and three it
might be higher four five six even seven
the stuff in your stomach is not just
acid you have other things you have an
enzyme okay it's usually an inactive
enzyme and then it converts to an active
enzyme pepsin is the active enzyme that
gets activated with acid that's a very
powerful protein enzyme okay that's one
of the purposes of your stomach is to
digest protein you don't want that
enzyme up in your esophagus why because
your esophagus is also a protein okay so
it'll start dissolving yourself we don't
want that now what makes that enzyme
active is the pH being acid okay very
acid if that solution is to alkaline the
enzyme will not become active it stays
inactive so another question is what
type of acid stimulates the active form
of this enzyme peptase well does it have
to be Hydrochloric like in your stomach
well actually no it can be another acid
it can be apple cider vinegar acetic
acid because that acid has a very low PH
okay now this also relates to some other
data about the stomach having your
stomach acid be between one and three
also will help release bile okay now if
you can't release bile from the liver
and the gallbladder what happens is that
you tend to get gallstones this is why
one of the big side effects from
antacids and ppis is gallstones now we
have pepsin which is activated by acid
but there's other enzymes too from your
pancreas enzymes that help you digest
carbohydrates to digest fats
so when you don't have enough
acid in your stomach you're going to get
less enzymes released from the pancreas
and less digestion also you need this
strong acid in your stomach to be able
to absorb not just minerals but also
trace minerals and vitamins as well so
you become very nutrient deficient when
you don't have the strong pH in your
stomach the other purpose of this acid
is to kill pathogens coming in from the
body as well as to kill bacteria so the
bacteria doesn't end up in your small
intestine and create a situation called
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
where you have these microbes living in
your small intestine and competing for
nutrition from your your food and
leaving you with a lot of problems
especially bloating and gas and all
sorts of issues now the other problem
with not enough stomach acid is that you
might get anemia because you can't
absorb iron and B12 adults there's this
other thing
that gets activated with this strong
stomach acid it's called the intrinsic
factor which I don't want to really get
into but just realize that if you don't
have enough stomach acid you're not
going to be able to absorb B12 which can
create all sorts of issues with not just
anemia but a lot of neurological
problems that can be irreversible okay
in certain cases the other point about
not having enough stomach acid is that
can increase your risk of H pylori
becoming a problem normally about 80
percent of the population has H pylori
in their stomach but it doesn't bother
them unless
you lose the stomach acid and then that
microbe can then become pathogenic and
create more issues okay so we don't even
necessarily need hydrochloric acid to
fix a lot of these issues you can use
this very inexpensive apple cider
vinegar the type of apple cider vinegar
that I'm recommending is not the Braggs
okay Braggs sold their company to
another company and I found out they're
diluting their apple cider vinegar if
you look in the back of the label they
add water so it's not as strong as it
should be instead I recommend another
company fairchilds okay it's a great
company I buy all my apple cider vinegar
from that company and I also buy the
apple cider vinegar for some of the
animals that I'm raising on my farm and
they love it I dilute it with water and
they're very very healthy okay so this
is a really simple solution you get some
organic apple cider vinegar okay and you
just have to use two tablespoons in a
glass of water it could be eight ounces
it could be 12 ounces and you drink that
before you eat okay that's the
Simplicity of it that will help lower
the ph it'll start to help your
digestion you don't want to take this
apple cider vinegar without diluting it
if you look at the problems of the apple
cider vinegar it's usually related to
someone not diluting with water and
drinking maybe a lot of it in there
swishing around their mouth and it could
affect their teeth so all you have to do
is just take a straw and then sip it so
it doesn't go into the tea and you'll be
fine now I also recommend other things
too if you want to take it to the next
level I would recommend going on omad
one meal per day okay why because now
you'll give your your system a chance to
reset and heal because it's the constant
eating and the frequent eating and all
the snacks that really disrupts the
digestive system and probably is one of
the underlying cause to this GERD
problem in the first place and then the
last thing I would recommend is cabbage
cabbage as a vegetable would be very
very important in any type of acid
reflux situation even ulcers it really
helps the stomach I'm not going to get
into why but you'll find that you can
digest cabbage better than other greens
and it will help you now just realize
that you'll probably have to do this for
some weeks or months to fully correct it
but you're going to feel a lot better
and of course I would also recommend a
certain eating plan if you have this
problem that would be called the healthy
Keto Plan and I will put a link down
below so you can download this eating
plan now this other point I want to
bring up is there a situation where your
stomach is producing too much acid yes
there is a condition okay but it's not
very common the most common condition is
something called hypochlorhydria that's
low stomach acid and one of the biggest
triggers for that is just getting older
so many people as they go into their 60s
70s 80s and 90s start just creating less
acid and they start having all these
issues with what I'm talking about a
more rare condition would be too much
acid and that does occur but usually
from three situations okay number one
zalinger Ellison uh syndrome basically
that's a condition where you have this
benign tumor in the stomach or small
intestine and is causing the cells to
produce too much acid basically another
situation would be if you have
autoimmune gastritis which is not as
common so the parietal cells that are
making the acid are being attacked by
antibodies and then there's a
compensatory situation where your body
is going to compensate and make more
acid until eventually you burn out that
cell and now it's not going to make as
much acid now you're going to end up
with no acid so you go from a hyper acid
state to a hypo acid State okay and then
the third situation for this sour
stomach or is production of too much
acid would be H pylori which I've
already covered and if you have H pylori
which is kind of a pathogenic situation
you want to take Mastic Gum garlic to
try to kill it off broccoli Sprouts on a
daily basis sulforaphane and broccoli
Sprouts is a potent way to kill off or
put this H pylori into a dormant stage
now one very very important point if
you're drinking upside of vinegar and
you feel worse the burning increases it
could mean that you have either
inflammation
in your stomach lining or in ulcer in
which case you don't want to take apple
cider vinegar right now you have to heal
this ulcer or this inflammation and for
that you want chlorophyll I recommend a
high quality raw wheatgrass juice powder
for that okay you take that and it does
take some weeks to heal that area and
then I also recommend the intermittent
fasting for sure and the healthy version
of the ketogenic plan as well as zinc
carnosine very very important then after
weeks of doing that when it's healed up
then you can go back to the opposite of
vinegar now another common remedy that
people use is betaine hydrochloride
that's another great remedy but this is
really just a no-brainer anyone has gerd
anyone who has indigestion bloating acid
reflux heartburn should definitely try
the apple cider vinegar because it works
so effectively now since we're on the
topic of digestion there's a lot more to
know about it I have a really Dynamite
video on digestion you have to check
this one out and I put that one up right
here